the whole white privilege idea is itself
a kind of luxury belief because i mean
first what's happening is that like the
people who seem to be most strident and
in favor of this white privilege idea
are themselves white
um
and what they're doing is they're
elevating their own status right like if
a white person at you know some fancy
college or whatever in in sort of a
position of prominence says you know oh
i decry white privilege is that white
person losing status or gaining status
right like are they hurting themselves
or are they actually elevating
themselves even more
among their peer group around the people
whose opinions they care about
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
man who coined the term luxury beliefs
he's a phd student at cambridge robert
henderson welcome to trigonometry thanks
guys great to be here it's great to have
you on uh before we get into talking
about luxury beliefs and i mean it's a
fascinating concept that you've
described and i really can't wait to
talk about it but before we do who are
you how are you where you are what has
been the journey through life that leads
you to be sitting here talking to us
right so my name is rob henderson like
you said i'm a phd student at cambridge
in my final year studying social and
evolutionary psychology uh before this i
was uh you know studying at yale also
studying psychology for my undergrad i
worked in the lab there as well in the
psychology department and so this is
just my sort of broad areas of interest
human nature psychology
uh evolutionary theory this kind of
stuff um
i mean before this i i suppose part of
what contributed to my
coming up with this idea of luxury
beliefs is my unusual path to higher
education so
uh to back way up i was born into
poverty
i never knew my father
i you know grew up in los angeles my
mother when i was three
became addicted to drugs she wasn't able
to care for me
and so i spent the next few years living
in foster homes around los angeles i
lived in seven different homes
throughout my childhood
i was adopted by this working class
family where we settled in northern
california
was eight years old
and
yeah so we grew up in this kind of dusty
town very poor
crime ridden town
and
yeah i mean there was still even though
i had been adopted there were still
divorces and separations and more sort
of turbulence and
uh you know all of this led me to really
not care about school about my studies i
got into a lot of trouble
and barely graduated high school
enlisted in the military when i was 17
right after i graduated
and got out of there and
yeah that sort of helped me to redirect
my life in a better direction
and from there i went to yale on the gi
bill she paid for tuition and that's
kind of where i ended up uh you know
here today
and so i lived my life through a series
of um you know basically
along the american status letter
different social classes starting off
you know about as poor as you can be in
a like a modern western country
and sort of grew up maybe more working
class after i'd been adopted when i was
in the military i had a lot of friends
who were maybe more sort of middle class
or middle class and then by the time i
got to yale i
had this
extreme culture shock
being around these students who were you
know very affluent upper middle or upper
class and of course cambridge as well
and so
i suppose my unusual experiences sort of
really informed my my views about class
and and uh and then later luxury beliefs
wow that is so fascinating man that is
you young guy you've already had you
know a couple of lifetimes worth of
experiences haven't you
and i suppose you talk about how that
that shapes you i think an outsider's
perspective is always valuable and
you've had an outsider's perspective to
many different worlds as opposed because
of your background right yeah i i guess
you know it's funny when i when i first
got to yale and
you know started seeing just just how
different things really were i never
actually thought of my life as that
unusual or strange i mean
the reason is because it was all i ever
knew so my my friends in high school had
very similar lives to me you know i had
like five good friends in high school my
five close you know circle of friends
and they were also raised by you know
like one of them his mother was addicted
to drugs his father went to prison he
was raised by his grandmother had
another friend was raised by a single
mom another one who was raised by
basically a single dad who had been
married five times throughout our
childhood like married in divorce just
sort of revolving
door of step parents and so this was
like what i knew this was my life you
know up until age 17 and the military
was a little different you know i met
some friends who had maybe somewhat
similar lives to me some were better
but um
you know i i just didn't really think of
my life as that that strange until i you
know entered these sort of more you know
unusual fancy universities and and
meeting people who had never met anyone
like me and that that was like when i i
realized like oh like the people who are
responsible for shaping culture for
politics responsible for shaping
politics the sort of future leaders of
the world have no idea what's going on
among sort of poor and working-class
people and what's going on with the
families and with you know with the kids
and just the sort of level of disorder
and instability and why do they not have
an idea is it because they're so wealthy
and privileged they're divorced from it
is it because
they have a disinterest what are the
reasons
yeah i'm not okay so why why would i
mean i think part of it is just um
living in a bubble um whether you live
in a sort of suburb or a gated community
or a place where money can shield you
from the day-to-day
uh uh sort of you know
what's what's happening with with uh
with people who maybe aren't as as
fortunate as you
i mean i saw a lot of this when i was
you know without yale for example so
it's this university is located in new
haven which is one of the poorest you
know cities in in the northeast very
rundown um i lived downtown in this this
area my my apartment was you know like
two or three blocks from from the campus
but i on the way there i had to walk
through a lot of poverty a lot of
homelessness
drug addiction mental illness and so on
and what i noticed that the students
very seldom left like the bubble of this
university you know like around the
campus there's a lot of security and
police and um you know
gates where you have to like use your
student card to access certain and so
it's like very safe and secure
it's a foreign it's a portrait yeah
literally that's how it is it's fortress
and you know i sometimes
it was really funny to me i i would like
you know go off campus and sometimes i'd
advise some of the other undergrads and
we'd go like you know downtown to eat or
something go to a restaurant and i could
see like they they suddenly became very
wary like like because they're not used
to it you know they're not used to being
in like a city where so with that sort
of level of uncertainty
and
you know is it their fault i don't know
but but yeah there is this sort of
distance and i think a lot of their
experience of you know poverty and you
know what's going on
is through
you know it's sort of filtered through
media through the sort of
um content they choose to consume which
is often sort of tailored to flatter
their own
viewpoints um rather than actually
seeing it up close and seeing what's
really going on so yeah i think those
are just yeah a few of the reasons okay
and what are these luxury beliefs that
these students had
yeah so luxury beliefs i define as ideas
and opinions that confer status on the
upper class while often inflicting costs
on the lower classes
um there are a few different pieces to
this for how i came up with this i mean
one i've you know sort of been
discussing just my sort of first hand
experiences
um but at the same time i had also been
reading a lot of like sort of old school
sociology from thorstein babelin and
pierre bourdue and you know basically
they said that
the way that people used to demonstrate
their social class was through material
goods through sort of expensive items
luxury goods
and so you know for example if you if
you walked through
the streets of
new york or or london too you know 100
years ago you could tell immediately
just by how people were dressed how much
money they had you know this person is
wealthy this person maybe not so wealthy
today it's not necessarily the case you
don't really it's it's a much noisier
signal what someone is wearing
and how it correlates to how much money
they have in the bank um and so this was
puzzling to me because i also saw a lot
of this too where students would sort of
downplay their wealth or even lie about
you know how rich their parents were um
and so what's going on here but but
but then at the same time i was also
reading
sort of more modern social psychology
papers within the last just couple of
years
and what social psychology research
indicates is that the people who care
the most about wealth and status are the
people who already have it so if you
basically take these measures of you
know you ask people you know basically
your socioeconomic status your level of
income your sort of position in society
how well you're doing at your job
occupational success and so on um and
then you ask people questions like you
know how much would it interest you to
hold a position of power how important
is it for you to have influence over
other people sort of measurements of
your interest and status um
and wealth and so on those two things
are positively correlated meaning sort
of the higher up in society you are the
more you care about those things and so
this was puzzling to me because i saw
okay so people these you know sort of
affluent upper middle class and upper
class people really care about status
um based on this research but they're
not doing it through their material
goods you know the way that they dress
they sort of downplay it they sort of
dress down in a way so what's going on
here and then i realized oh it's luxury
beliefs it's the unusual and novel
viewpoints that they're expressing to
sort of
uh distinguish themselves you know they
create distinction that's the key goal
here distinguish themselves from the
sort of middle class or working-class
people who you know if someone in
society holds a conventional opinion a
very easy way to show that you're not a
member of the sort of the the riff raff
or the masses or something is to hold
the opposite opinion or hold a strange
opinion that maybe doesn't make sense
because it shows like you
uh
you're not one of them and then the way
that you it's not just the opinion
itself but it's the way that you express
it if you express it in
you know using using vocabulary no one
has ever heard of for example and i can
tell a couple of stories about that too
you know sort of my the culture shock
that i had uh learning this you know
strange words and lexicon and so tell us
some of that
well okay so
so one example my first my first year i
um
i try to join this like humor writing
magazine on campus it's a student-run
thing
um
and we were
brainstorming ideas for headlines for
that month so the month's
theme for that magazine issue was
puberty and so we were just spitballing
ideas putting them up on the whiteboard
and i
you know it was i think it had been yeah
it's been like four months you know
since i'd entered the university and
still pretty new to me
and i came up with this uh headline of
something like area mail discovers porn
gold mine in his front right pocket
um
and
then the student editor uh looks at me
and he raises an eyebrow and he's like
why does it have to be gendered
and i look at him like what like
what's gender
i i never heard that i knew what gender
was you know male female whatever but
gendered ed like
why would you make it into an adjective
and i just sort of you know like okay
slunk back like okay what is he talking
about here but yeah there were other
cases you know eventually google would
learn like all kinds of
terms that i had never heard before um
you know heteronormative cisgender
cultural appropriation was another one
that i learned well were you not talking
about that when you were growing up or
you weren't talking about
heteronormativity i had never heard that
you know and what's funny is that for a
period of my youth uh from yeah
basically like through my high school
years my
like middle school high school years my
adoptive mother uh entered a
relationship with a woman and they
raised me together for like a few years
and so they were progressive
i mean but they were they were like
working class democrats my you know my
my mother and her partners and and so
you know i i had like familiarity with
like gay culture and stuff just through
living you know living with them but i'd
never heard any of these terms before
and you know even now sometimes i'll go
visit my mom and ask her some questions
and stuff and she's like what are you
doing what are they talking about at
that school of years like what's going
on over there um it's almost like you
can be gay without having the language
well
like a lot of it is like it's it's it's
based on on class right like it's sort
of if you
you know
straight people at these schools learn
this vocabulary right like it's it's
more a matter of
who you're around what um
what kind of culture you're exposed to
the amount of money people have around
you whether you have time
to consume like what do you have the
time to like sit around all day and like
scroll twitter social media keep up with
the latest fashionable trends
reading op-eds and whatever the latest
news you know this whole there's right
now there's this whole thing about like
the current thing right like you know
can you keep up with the current thing
well if you work a blue collar job and
you can't look at your phone all day
because you're i don't know you're a bus
driver i don't know whatever it is like
you can't like you know oh let me check
my phone every hour and see what's uh
you know what's trending um and so that
was something new too like i would have
these encounters with with students
where they would say you know oh did you
read this by so and so some op-ed or
something in the atlantic or something
and i would say no like what are you
guys reading the news for like what's
like why do you care you know you're 19.
why do you care what's going on like
shouldn't you be like having fun and
whatever and and and then i grew to
realize like oh part of part of um
enculturation you know sort of
assimilation into this upper classes
sort of being very aware like what's
going on politically what's going on the
news what are the you know and so you
know uh listening to the right podcasts
reading the right periodicals
uh the right tv shows and movies what's
what's sort of hot right now in terms of
the sort of latest luxury belief
trend and
and so that was that was new to me you
know i grew up we had never really
like consumed that much political
content i mean we couldn't afford cable
so we didn't have like msnbc or fox news
or any of this we subscribed to the
local paper you know like red bluff
daily news but then i get to you know to
yale and it was like reading the new
york times or the wall street journal
they have stacks of this they're trying
to give these papers away to these
students they offer these steep
discounts because they want to hook the
students in and become lifetime
subscribers to the and so you can
constantly keep up with what's going on
and this is an indicator of
of of your class right like do you know
what's going on
uh
can you sort of describe events that are
happening far removed from you do you
have the time the ability to consume all
of it it's sort of an indicator of your
you know the comforts of your everyday
life
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthem has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
back in the day um so so vablin uh he
was a sociologist and economist he wrote
theory of the leisure class in 1899
and
he wrote about how you know like even
things like soft hands you know these
are indicators of um
of sort of your social rank in society
because you know you don't do manual
labor um
uh art like do you wear sort of delicate
and restrictive clothing tuxedos evening
gowns do you go golfing and beagling do
you sort of partake in these these
activities that require a lot of
investment of time to learn how to do
like you know mastering golf takes a lot
of time um
and wearing certain kinds of clothes and
so on and and today it's it's uh it's
it's sort of shifted
away from
expensive and time-consuming uh hobbies
or expensive clothes and towards sort of
uh your luxury beliefs and and i can
give you like specific examples of the
beliefs that i was seeing too okay well
i was going to say i suppose the
difference would be that in the past
with a luxury uh luxury set of behaviors
you were the one paying the price if you
went out and you golfed for well you had
to be able to afford that if you went
out and you bought a tuxedo and walked
around it you had to be able to afford
it you had to be invited to places where
tuxedos were welcome
you paid the price
you paid the price but with luxury
beliefs it ain't you paying the price is
it
yeah well
okay so you often are not paying the
price for your luxury beliefs but my
claim is that you know
in in the articles i've written about
this is that even even if you do you
know pay a price for it it's still not
nearly the same as the cost inflicted on
the lower classes if they were to adopt
those luxury beliefs too
um
so give us the examples now and let's
talk about them okay so so for example
um
so i had this conversation on recently
with uh this is a couple years ago now
with a former classmate of mine
um you know she went to
yale she works at a sort of a well-known
technology company she's doing very well
for herself but she was telling me that
she thinks that monogamy is outdated and
that marriage is this kind of like
patriarchal oppressive institution
oh manchester united
and so i'm listening to her i'm like
okay and then i asked her well how did
you grow up like how were you raised and
she said well i was raised by
my mom and dad and a kind of
conventional typical you know intact
family
and then i asked okay so then
are you
going to do something different or are
you going to do like what do you plan to
do with your family later on you know
and she said i'll probably do the same
thing i'll probably get married and i'll
get a husband and have kids like that i
said but then why are you talking about
marriage being outdated you know it just
didn't make sense to me like why are you
saying one thing but then you're going
to do this other set of behaviors and
she said well i'm just like she said
like well just because my preference
doesn't mean has to be for everyone you
know like i think society can evolve
beyond you know this this norm having to
be
uh uh you know sort of implemented and
and and sort of promoted in society you
know just because i want to do it just
my preference but you know i think we
can evolve beyond it and i'm thinking to
myself like so you were raised by this
intact family you did very well in your
life you're going to have probably an
intact family and your kids are going to
inherit a lot of the benefits of like
that kind of lifestyle but you're
promoting this other view you know she's
sort of amplifying this this opposing
view of you know uh we need to get past
monogamy we need to get past marriage
and so on
and this is a luxury belief this belief
that family doesn't matter or we should
evolve beyond monogamy or that like sort
of the stability that that cultivates is
unimportant
and
this this is like you know probably my
original observation of a luxury belief
i remember distinctly when i was was in
this classroom
at yale and there was a seminar of about
20-something students
and
the the professor administered this
anonymous poll
um to the class and the question was
basically um you know were you raised by
both of your birth parents
and you know none of like i wasn't
talked about that but none of my friends
were either like that the group of six
of us none of us were raised by both of
our birth parents this professor
administered this poll and i wasn't sure
what to expect but when the results came
in you know she put it up on the on her
slides and it was um out of 20-something
students only two said no just me and
one other student i didn't know who it
was in the class
and the rest you know more than 90
and i was like what like what's going on
here and so this was shocking to me
because i'd i'd already known that a lot
of these people came from like
well-to-do families they had a lot of
money but i didn't realize just how
different their
lives were in terms of their family
structure and to me that's not a
coincidence that this the kinds of
people who tend to get into these kinds
of universities
are raised in sort of stable
you know
you know married parents in this sort of
monogamous relationship outdated
oppressive but you know somehow they got
into this
and um
and so so
if you look at the data for example of
of sort of what's going on with
working class and poor families so in
1960
uh regardless of social class in the u.s
95 of children were raised by both of
their birth parents whether you're rich
whether you were poor this was just the
sort of cultural norm it was the
expectation
and then if you fast forward to 2005
the upper class sort of educated
affluent people
it dropped slightly to 85 percent so it
was 95 1960 and then dropped to 85
percent in 2005
whereas if you look at working class and
poor people it was 95 in 1960 and by
2005 it had plummeted to 30 percent what
30 30 yeah 30 meaning it's you're you're
an anomaly now if you grow up in a
low-income community and you're raised
by both of your parents um to me even
that number seemed high because i didn't
really know i knew i knew i think one
kid who was sort of like in my sort of
social circle or whatever who had that
um
but you know that was like very unusual
so even 30 seemed a little high to me um
and so it's really just night and day
you know if you walk around a sort of uh
upper middle class neighborhood like
you'll see a lot of married parents but
then if you ask a lot of those people
what do you think about marriage
monogamy norms and so on a lot of them
will sort of express this view like ah
it doesn't have to be for everyone or
like all you know
whatever works you know families are
kind of all the same and it you know
what we what we do doesn't necessarily
have to be for everyone that kind of
thing um
and
that belief like you know much of it
originated in the early 1960s and later
the sort of cultural and sexual
revolution during that time
a lot of it from college campuses highly
educated people were promoting this view
that you know marriage is oppressive and
all of this kind of stuff and
the belief trickled and was amplified
throughout society through
the media through pop culture through
movies and so on
and the norm eroded and the people who
promoted uh the view that the norm
should be eroded continue to get married
at very high rates and sort of adhere to
this
uh set of practices and beliefs that
benefited themselves and their own
children while inflicting costs on the
lower classes
um
i'll give you a modern kind of uh
version of this i talked to a friend of
mine who um he was telling me you know
when i set my uh my tinder radius to one
mile just outside of the you know
basically just around the university
and i see the the bios of you know the
women that he's you know swiping on or
whatever he says that like a lot of
their profiles you know they say things
like uh like paulie or you know uh
keeping it casual basically saying like
you know they're not interested in
anything too serious um he says like
something like half of them have like
something like that in their bio
and then he said but when i expand the
radius on my tinder to like five miles
to include sort of the rest of the city
and its outskirts a sort of more
run-down area beyond the university
bubble uh he says like half the women
are single moms
you know and basically the luxury
beliefs of the former group the educated
group trickled down and ended up having
this outsized effect on the people who
are
less fortunate who don't have high
levels of education economic capital who
can
you know basically the people who can
afford that belief you know because even
if you're even if you are a single
mother uh but you're doing very well for
yourself economically you can sort of
make that work for you but if you're
very low income very poor
and you're a single mother you have a
completely different experience right
and so maybe it is the case to some
degree um that if you're very affluent
uh you can sort of choose your family
and you'll in all likelihood your kid
will be okay but if you're very poor
it's a completely different experience
right and so this was sort of the
original view that i found for for
luxury beliefs uh sort of prime example
of it
do you think these people are utopians
rob they've got this idea of you know
we're all gonna get to this incredible
magical place with these beliefs
but
real life doesn't work like that
yeah i mean i think
much of it is uh sincere i don't you
know i think like a lot of it is like uh
if you sort of let people live their
lives and you don't have to have
cultural guard rails or sort of
norms that kind of serve as safety nets
for people that you know
they'll be okay
um
and i think there is maybe a utopian
undercurrent to it
um
but to me it it it more reflects a sort
of abdication of responsibility you know
if you if you
uh are fortunate enough to
you know have some influence and some
wealth and some
uh kind of status in society you know
like
you i think you have some some duty to
think like well what are like good norms
like what's a good way to live your life
and
to promote those norms you know like i
noticed that a lot of um sort of
affluent people they're very um
you know they're sort of uh okay with
with promoting things like like
financial assistance for example you
know whether it's the welfare state or
what have you sort of state benefits for
people
and you know i'm not opposed to that
fine like if people need financial
assistance that's fine um
but at the same time like money is not
the only thing
that can give rise to a good life right
like you can't just give everyone uh you
know ubi or something and then expect
them to live happily ever after like
also what contributes to a happy life
is sort of living by a set of norms and
behaviors and so forth um
and also to like
you know a lot of a lot of this is also
for kids right like kids don't get a
choice for how they live their life
right like you know most kids would
rather live in a sort of stable secure
safe family environment
and so yeah it's so so a lot of these
luxury beliefs not only do they affect
sort of adults who are sort of poor
working class but but the kids are the
ones who actually suffer well they hurt
the kids the most and this is kind of i
mean we're joking around as we want to
do and you're a very sort of cheerful
academic guy and you talk about but this
is [ __ ] awful
yeah this is awful you've got rich and
privileged and wealthy people
essentially destroying the very things
that poor people need to make their
lives better in order to make the rich
and wealthy people and powerful people
feel higher status at their dinner party
yeah [ __ ] awful yeah yeah yeah i mean
it is so so if you express these views
you will often sort of elevate your
status among your you know similarly
educated and affluent peers who will say
like yeah yeah of course monogamy is
outdated this is great and you sort of
give yourself a little status boost but
as that belief sort of percolates
throughout society it does have have
detrimental consequences i mean going
back to that idea about like you know
financial assistance and living a good
life and so on i mean there's there's
some interesting research in i think
these were uh done by economists who
basically sort of calculated the
monetary value of of sort of certain
aspects of of of sort of social life for
example um
so they calculated that being married
has the same effect on happiness as
earning an extra hundred thousand
dollars a year wow um
and and so so like one sort of simple
simplified interpretation of this is
well if you want to make people happier
you can give them 100 000 a year or you
can promote marriage right like if both
of us have the same effect on happiness
like what is the sort of metric of
interest here is it sort of making
people have a lot of money or is it
making people happier right like i think
happiness is probably more like life
satisfaction or well-being and there's
other sort of aspects of this too like
having uh having a friend that you see
on a regular basis was worth i think
ninety thousand dollars a year talking
to your neighbors regularly was worth
forty thousand 000 a year so basically
cultivating um social cohesion and
marriage and friendship and all this
stuff like having uh having an active
and good social life um seems to have
like this sort of outside so if you do
all those things i mean even things like
like religion i mean i'm not a
particularly religious person but the
benefits of religion are are pretty
clear that for example if you um
go to a religious service once a week it
has the same effect on happiness as
moving from the bottom uh income
quintile to the top income quintile
right and so basically if you're a
relatively low income person but you're
married and you have a friend and you
talk to your neighbors and you go to a
religious service your level of
happiness is the same basically as like
a very sort of wealthy person um but we
spend a lot of time talking about sort
of wealth and equality and so on which i
think that is an important topic but
often these other sort of the the sort
of norms that give rise to happiness are
often overlooked
rob
when this i started to become aware of
these subjects the luxury beliefs as you
said
someone put forward this argument about
privilege
and it always stuck with me actually
which was
one of the things about having privilege
is that you're not aware that you have
privilege and to a certain extent i'm
sympathetic to that idea
don't you think that we can also use our
argument with these people who put
forward these luxury beliefs
if you've always grown up wealthy if
you've always grown up in
you don't realize in many ways how lucky
you are because you've never seen the
flip side of it
so you're putting forward these
arguments
and it's coming from ignorance really
because you've got no idea of the
ramification that these things are going
to have further down the line that's a
good point you know
one of the one of the things i've been
thinking about is how
i mean
so
a lot of a lot of affluent people i
think have like at least attempted to
imagine what it's like to be poor maybe
through you know watching movies or tv
shows or something like you see like oh
like this might be like
you know because i think that's like a
lot of a lot of like you know sort of
where where people get their their views
from right is sort of uh entertainment
and pop culture and and so they at least
attempt to put themselves in in that
position of what would it be like to
have no money
um i don't think i've ever met a
sort of upper middle class or affluent
person who um has ever tried to imagine
what it would be like to grow up without
their family you know without their
parents without sort of that kind of
stability of reliable caretakers
and to me this is uh
this is important because
if you look at
so for example so developmental and
evolutionary psychologists make this
distinction between
uh childhood harshness and childhood
instability
and harshness is is basically low income
low socioeconomic status in your family
and uh childhood instability uh includes
things like a number of relocations in
your childhood whether there was a
father present in the home
uh whether the parents were divorced how
many different romantic partners the uh
child's parents had when they were
growing up and so on just sort of the
day-to-day disorder that they
experienced
and
literally every single
paper i've looked at investigating these
two things finds that childhood
instability is a much stronger predictor
of harmful and risky behaviors in
adulthood compared to childhood um
poverty or low income
uh you know so there was a pretty widely
studied 2012 study showing that um
you know childhood instability was a
significant predictor of you know an
adulthood so sort of the number of
short-term sexual partners teen
pregnancy rates um
rates of addiction likelihood of
committing a crime and so on uh whereas
childhood socioeconomic status was not
associated with any of those outcomes in
adulthood and there was another study
on 2016 which found that
regardless of family income
uh
adolescents who were raised in
instability were more likely to be
committed to drugs
and this had this was across
socioeconomic lines so basically a rich
teenager who grows up in instability is
more likely to become addicted to drugs
than a poor teenager raised in a stable
home um and so basically like this sort
of day-to-day disorder and instability
has a much stronger effect i mean
there's even some interesting research
on on personality and it sort of links
with with instability so
uh there's this um
uh idea in in psychology called the dark
triad personality traits um so
narcissism psychopathy machiavellianism
and you know this is like associated
with cynicism hostility disregard for
other people
and again so childhood instability was
significantly
uh associated with with these dark triad
traits in adulthood whereas childhood
poverty was not associated with any of
them and if anything i've actually seen
kind of the reverse there's this
interesting finding that um
low childhood socioeconomic status was
associated with slightly higher
scores on empathy in adulthood so people
who grow up poorer seem to actually have
slightly higher levels of empathy than
people who grew up rich whereas
childhood instability had a completely
opposite effect like if you grew up in
instability your ability to feel empathy
for other people is is um very much
declined uh diminished in adulthood
which might explain why there's more
violent crime particularly in some of
those eras potentially you know we had
dr dana fleischmann one of our favorite
guests
uh on the show and we in the first entry
do remember we talked about
in that particular context we talked
about why women were more attracted some
women were more attracted to people with
the dark triad characteristics and she
talked about how if you grow up in an
unstable environment and you see people
cheating each other screwing each other
over lying to each other and whatever
you sort of learn that to survive in
that environment you have to be like
that so that that makes perfect sense
um
but you know particularly the the the
family uh the lack of family intactness
issue
why is it do you think part of the
reason that the luxury beliefs around
that have shifted over time is that i
and maybe i'm curious to know why you
think it's happened is we've got to a
point where i think people in sort of
the chattering classes as we call them
in the uk
it's become sort of like
oh you can't tell other people how to
live their lives like
like it's much better to just give them
money and benefits than it is to like go
maybe we should all do this or we should
where's that like
i know i feel uncomfortable i feel
uncomfortable sitting there going maybe
people should get married before they
you know like what i'm some sort of like
conservative from the 1980s i'm going to
start shutting down comedians and
whatever like that's not who i am and i
feel that so where's that coming from
yeah i mean i think it's uh i mean
i feel it too you know whenever i talk
about this stuff especially early on
when i first started publicly expressing
these views like yeah there was
something and i and i think it's just um
you know for better or worse people uh
desire
like they don't want to be ostracized
they don't want to be vilified or
ridiculed for their views and i think
like this is actually part of part of
like this is how how sort of norms
rise and fall
is is not just through um
sort of people who are are unwilling to
impose them but also uh
another normal rises in itself that that
uh you will be punished for for trying
to promote it right and so this is sort
of what happens where like initially it
was just uncool to talk about marriage
and stuff and then and then pretty soon
like if you talked about it other the
norm became like how dare you say that
you know and this actually sort of
further uh uh accelerates the erosion of
that norm and so so yeah a lot of the
the behaviors that that that are you
know on average pretty beneficial uh not
just for the people but for kids and so
on uh
one contributor was was this view that
like oh like now no one wants to speak
out about it no one wants to express the
view and and this is you know why why a
lot of people are sort of pushing back
now and i think saying that like it is
important to express your viewpoints and
and so on so yeah i think that is you
know
people people who believe in these
things they need to get over it and
start talking more about it you know one
concept that always boils my urine to
put it mildly is when i see wealthy
middle class white people talking about
white privilege
and i'm like you have never stepped foot
outside of the city of london if you do
it's because you're going on holiday to
a very nice part of europe or to your
you know your summer residence you've
never been to a part of the uk like
cornwall where people grow up
in poverty where towns are depressed
there are no jobs so it's just
generation after generation of
unemployment or in the northeast for
example
and the fact that they just sit there
and spout this just makes me so angry
yeah
yeah it really is a kind of a like a
narrow-minded blinkered view of
yeah i guess just race and culture and
society is just
because what they're really saying is
like the only the only white people i
interact with are the rich ones you know
and a lot of those people themselves who
are expressing this view are themselves
like rich and white you know i mean
what's what's interesting is that a lot
of the sort of non-white people they
interact with are also sort of much
better off than their you know uh
counterparts in you know more deprived
areas and so
you know the whole white privilege idea
is itself a kind of luxury belief
because i mean first what's happening is
that like the people who seem to be most
strident and in favor of this white
privilege idea are themselves white
um
and what they're doing is they're
elevating their own status right like if
a white person at you know some fancy
college or whatever in in sort of a
position of prominence says you know oh
i decry white privilege is that white
person losing status or gaining status
right like are they hurting themselves
or are they actually elevating
themselves even more uh among their peer
group around the people whose opinions
they care about and by the way are they
getting more privileges as a result
right because if you if you're a white
person who's in the creative industries
as we once were before we self-canceled
yeah right then if the more you talk
about the stuff the more opportunities
you get
the more money you get paid right so you
are actually entrenching your privilege
by advancing this concept yeah yeah yeah
you get yeah invitations and
you at the very least you're not
inhibiting your own opportunities
because if you deny white privilege you
may actually hurt yourself to some
degree so by espousing it you're
actually sort of maintaining and
elevating it
and and you know this whole
concept of white privilege was
mystifying to me when i first
encountered it because yeah like where i
grew up in new york northern so when i
was growing up the foster homes probably
most of my foster siblings were you know
they were like hispanic black and a
couple white kids here and there but uh
in red bluff it was like much more sort
of working class white and hispanic and
you know my best friend some of them
were like basically poor white kids you
know like raised by you know single moms
or alcoholic stepdads or whatever and
i'm like okay well whatever like that
wasn't privileged for them you know like
what what is like this whole white
privilege idea it really just seems to
be wealth privilege and people are just
trying to like use this concept to
i guess sound sophisticated or to
elevate themselves or to undermine
competitors
um the whole the whole concept of it is
just um
yeah it's it's it's very silly
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy dns is a company for you easy dns
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies
he knows about that so will you in a
second
easy dns have rock-solid network
infrastructure and fantastic customer
support they're in your corner no matter
what the world throws at you unless it's
your ex-girlfriend in which case you're
on your own you know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is go to easydns.com
forward slash triggered that's
easydns.com
forward slash triggered use our promo
code which is also triggered and get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter access of easy which
tells you everything you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
do you think part of this what we're
talking about here and i think maybe
it's less applicable for america than it
is for the uk but it's rooted in
classism you've got the upper classes
who go we're the thinkers we're the
intelligent ones we're the harvard yale
educated people correct yeah we know
what's good for you um
the working classes so we'll do the
thinking
and we've got these ideas do you think
part of it is that or is that my chip on
my shoulder i think there's some truth
to that i mean
yeah there's this sort of uh
overconfidence this arrogance that is
that is sort of pervasive among highly
educated and affluent people who think
that they know better
who have
more time to spend on utopian ideas and
i mean like i've i'd never met someone
who um who had like this whole sort of
uh um like political theory before about
how society should be run until i sort
of joined this new social environment
and these new class and interacting with
different kinds of people and that's
just like not something you know first
you don't have time but then you just i
think there's also this craving for like
power to exercise over people i think
the vast majority of people just want to
be left alone you know they just want to
sort of live their lives go to work you
know
spend time with their loved ones and so
on but
a lot of elite institutions attract to
the kind of personality who is
interested in power i mean i mentioned
that study before people who are
interested in wealth and status are
already have it and they're interested
in getting more of it and so they sort
of collect the credentials and inhabit
elite institutions and so forth and part
of the reason for that is because they
have an idea in mind about how things
should be
and they're very interested in
attempting to to enact their favorite
policies and so on and
so i think there is um there is some
truth to that and again like i think a
lot of this isn't necessarily due to
malice you know there's not but they
their hearts are you know many of them
are in the right place
but they
just don't um
they're not thinking of the sort of
downstream second order effects of their
views that maybe sound good that maybe
you know get get accolades from their
peers but then when the rest of society
adopts it they they don't think through
okay well what would happen if this view
were to become popular right this has
always been my frustration because i've
always been you know i think i'm
probably one of those people in the
sense that i'm interested in thinking
about how society ought to be structured
how do we solve this problem how do we
solve that problem i've always been
since i was a kid but
what bothers me about a lot of this
discourse is
i think we're not really asking how do
we solve this problem we're asking what
makes me feel good and look good
if i express about this problem i i just
don't see that as a practical answer and
that's always been like the thing i
couldn't get my head around like these
people claim to be wanting to solve the
problem but the moment anyone actually
mentions the actual solutions everyone
has a meltdown and freaks out and says
well you can't say that and we mustn't
talk about this so there's a kind of
impracticality to it and what worries me
based on what you're describing is of
course our media class our political
class our educational system all of
those institutions are largely staffed
and populated and run
by the very people you're talking about
right yeah yeah i mean it's uh i think
it's to some degree it is concerning
uh that the people who
you know there's
there's a sort of a competing
competing motives i suppose you know on
the one hand you know people do care
about what's going on in society and how
to improve lives for other people i mean
very few people are like how do i make
things worse you know they want to make
things better but then there's this
other motive of uh sort of
uh
obtaining validation from your peers of
doing well in your career and and in
many of these institutions your career
hinges on the opinions of other people
um and so
oftentimes the sort of self-interest
wins out right like or you're able to
do the
intellectual acrobatics necessary to
convince yourself that this sort of
silly sounding idea this luxury belief
will somehow make things better you can
sort of talk yourself into it and you
know coincidentally enough it just
happens to align with your self-interest
and will advance your career when you
espouse it at the same time and i think
a lot of people don't take the time to
step back and think like okay am i
expressing this view because i really
believe it am i expressing it because it
benefits me am i expressing it because
you know other other people around me
seem to like it and it's helping my
career i mean what is really going on
here what would really help other people
and i think more people should should
maybe step back and reflect rob i'm
going to ask a question now which
is a question i asked myself and it's
starting to happen every day look at the
way we're dressed look at who we are are
we
am i conservative is that what's
happening here that we just i'm dressed
like a conservative yeah
i get an email every day from someone
goes t-shirt and blazer dress up a bit
mate what's wrong with you
there's a guy in india messages me once
a month just to say that
in india only criminals dress like this
correct thanks mate
all right hold on to my wallet
but but but it's do you see what i mean
are we just be are we just conservative
are we just becoming those those
middle-aged guys who are railing against
young people hey i'm still young
what is this why are you trying to
destroy me
do you know what i mean though
yeah i mean
maybe i you know it's it's funny like
people okay so i mean of course in like
the sort of political science political
psychology research a lot of it does
seem to indicate that as you grow older
people do tend to become you know
someone more conservative in their their
attitudes
i mean the other thing is like maybe
maybe societal trends have gone so far
in a direction that we didn't anticipate
that
you know
i mean what is this whole term
conservative i mean there's so many you
know
contentious debates about what it even
means but i mean
if you
if you study
you know history
and cultural anthropology and sort of
how have people lived their lives i mean
marriage as an institution arose
independently in multiple different
places across multiple different
cultures and different times and so
forth
and to me i don't know if it's
conservative or not but there is
something um you know worthy of our
attention that if all of these different
cultures came up with the same idea
independently and it seemed
maybe to have solved some kind of
societal problem for them
that maybe we should think very
carefully before we start to dismantle
it and erode it and so on and so i mean
there i mean there are other examples of
this but but yeah if if uh if something
has endured and stood the test of time
then maybe it arose for a reason and not
just out of you know ignorance or or
just from being sort of backwards or
something and i'm just you know
oftentimes very skeptical that
you know we're the ones who have it all
figured out and all you know every other
culture throughout history across time
around the globe like they're they're
the ones who are wrong and i'm you know
we're the ones who get it right it just
seems very unlikely but here's the thing
with your question as well francis i've
been thinking about this a lot like
the idea that one side of the political
debate is right and the other one is
wrong it's the most moronic thing i've
ever heard right because the discussion
between more change or less change which
is essentially the debate right
conservatives want things to stay more
the same and progressive people tend to
want things to change faster that's
always existed in society and there
would have been times in society in the
history of different societies where you
absolutely needed to be progressive you
needed to change things because the
status quo was awful right
and there's times when actually you got
to a place where things were pretty good
and you'd want to keep them stable right
so the idea that you in your own life
over a period of 80 years
are gonna be like have one position and
that position is gonna is gonna be the
right one you might get lucky in that
you live in a society where like you
know everything's great for 80 years and
you don't ever need to change anything
but that's unlikely right so that's why
i always refuse to commit myself to
either of these tribes because i'm like
well on some things at some points in
time in some geographical locations
being progressive is brilliant like in
russia where i come from i'm a
progressive right in the uk people think
i'm on the right right i'm actually
neither i'm just going like this
society's pretty good let's kind of like
maybe not destroy it whereas that
society it's got some good things about
it but it does need a lot of you know
change to move into the 21st century
please at some point you know what i
mean and that that to me is really like
the sensible way to look at politics
because what is appropriate today in the
uk may be completely inappropriate what
is you know to to what was happening
somewhere in sri lanka 20 years ago do
you know what i mean i do yeah so we are
conservative
i mean it's interesting i mean like
you're saying these terms are are are
flexible they're fluid depending on
where you are depending on the point in
history where you are i mean even
you know uh
i mean if you existed 20 years ago you
would probably be on the left right but
things are changing
so yeah
i mean yeah so yeah i mean i was yeah i
was probably more on the left you know
10 or 15 years ago whatever too and
things change i mean
people individually change but then the
culture changes around them too and like
you said even by country you know in one
country or this in another country or
that and so the labels don't always map
on to anything
stable or concrete and so
yeah i mean i think often these are just
like convenient ways to divide people
and to get them to you know bicker and
and go back and forth and and for you
know people to make money off of this
rob
we've got to wrap up in a bit but one
thing that i wanted to ask you at the
beginning but i i wanted to talk about
your academic work but if you forgive me
for saying this you're a remarkable guy
the life you've just you've had already
is incredible like going growing up the
way you did with all of that instability
and you talk about statistically
speaking that can cause a lot of
difficulties and yet you sit here as a
phd student in your last year at
cambridge you've been at yale you've
been in the mid lake you've had an
extraordinary life like what are some of
the qualities or some of the approaches
or some of the ways of thinking that you
think are important for people who face
some of the challenges that you faced as
a kid i mean you know so this is a
question i get and it's it's uh it's
always hard like i'm always i guess
reluctant to give an answer because
there's no like one size fits all this
is what works for every kid i mean for
me it was really like you know i i
joined
the military right out of high school
and that was you know the military is
like this the most sort of intense
coercive
environment you can be in
where every aspect of your life is
tightly controlled and that was exactly
what i needed uh but that's not what
most people need or many people do right
like i wouldn't necessarily recommend
going through that path that i went
through but it was what i needed at that
time given the sort of level of chaos
and instability in my early life i
needed basically the opposite of that in
the military where like you know here's
step by step here's what you're supposed
to do like you know your uniform the way
you make your bed like all of this stuff
was just so tightly controlled was that
a difficult adjustment for you it was
very difficult i mean i thought it was
ridiculous but but at the same time like
there was something attractive about it
because like my supervisors and mentors
and commanding officers and so forth
like these were you know like
male figures like father figures or
whatever like these were guys that i
respected you know oftentimes it was
begrudging respect but i understood like
you know these this is the first time
that i've met like a you know an adult
male who i would want to emulate or that
i admire in some way or something and so
you know and then all part of it was
like i knew that they had to do all of
this stuff that i'm doing too and they
would tell us like you know we had to do
that too like you know so shut up and do
it and
and so like that also sort of added to
my respect that like they sort of walked
the walk kind of thing um but but yeah
like and it took a lot of work too i
mean i was in i you know it was just a
it was a long process
of sort of self-development
self-improvement and so on to get you
know to sort of what like leave behind
the sort of mindset and the bad habits
and everything that i had picked up uh
throughout my my childhood and
adolescence but but i mean for for a lot
of kids i mean i think just finding that
stability in any form whether it's
through uh sports or finding a mentor
finding someone who takes like an
interest has a stake in your future who
cares about you
um yeah that would be that would go a
long way i think to helping a lot of
kids i found your answer really
illuminating because the one thing you
pointed out was this is the first time i
met male role models that i wanted to
emulate that is so powerful rob because
when i talk in in underprivileged
schools and really poor areas of london
the kids who were all struggling i'd be
able to go farther in at home dad isn't
around blah blah blah
yeah yeah i mean it's it's
fatherlessness is a is a huge problem
that very few people uh are talking
about i mean i of course i saw it but
then you know i volunteered um as a
tutor too for for underprivileged kids
and it's it's the same story very few of
them have have uh fathers at home and
it's uh yeah this is a huge problem
having role models i think for for young
males um you know that that absence that
sort of lack even if even if young
boys or males can't like consciously
express it whether because they're not
aware of it of that absence and the
importance it plays you know that that
role or or or just out of pride that
they don't want to admit that they want
it i mean but that that does sort of
have a detrimental effect on a lot of
kids i think absolutely rob it's been an
absolute pleasure i'm sure you're going
to write a book about luxury beliefs at
some point and we'll we'll good luck to
have you back on to talk about it in
more detail i know you've before that
book which you'll write eventually
you've got another one coming out soon
uh tell us a little bit about that yeah
i'm writing a memoir based on my early
life experiences growing up in foster
homes in los angeles and sort of my
unusual
path to higher education and
the book also contains some some uh
commentary and observations about uh
society and culture and and maybe some
things that we should be thinking more
about well i can't wait to read it send
us a copy would you when it comes out
and uh before we let you go we've got as
always one final question for you before
we do our questions for our local
supporters of course which is what's the
one thing we're not talking about as a
society that you think we really should
be ah yeah i mean i think we've touched
on uh a lot of a lot of the you know
important topics to me anyway i mean i
think childhood instability would
probably be the number one question you
know i mean i mean again like we talk a
lot about
poverty and and economic deprivation but
i think sort of instability for for
children is something we should be
thinking more about rob it's been an
absolute pleasure if people want to find
you online where is the best place to do
that uh yeah i launched my sub stack a
few weeks ago
robkhenderson.substance.com
and they can follow me on twitter at rob
k henderson fantastic thanks for coming
on rob and thank you guys for watching
and listening we'll see you very soon
with another brilliant episode like this
one or all show all of them go out at
7pm uk time and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
of all the luxury beliefs you've
identified which strikes you as the most
luxurious and why
oh man
you